Малювання суто емоційно заспокоює.
Я вранці прокинулася і розумію, що мені нікуди не треба.
Тобто мені нічим себе зайняти.
Відволікати треба себе від дурних думок:
що робити далі? А як жити? А чи є взагалі сенс?
Отакі-от навіть.
Ользі Ткаченко 21 рік.
Вона може розфарбовувати ось такі розмальовки годинами.
Ще вона може годинами читати. Бо майже не виходить з квартири.
З дитинства в неї орфанна,  тобто рідкісна хвороба -
ювенільний ревматоїдний артрит - ЮРА.
Якщо коротко, йдеться про хронічне запалення усіх суглобів і нестерпний біль.
Пам’ятаю, мене якось запитували, як це, коли болить.
Мені здається, найоптимальніша відповідь на це питання -
я не знаю, як це, коли не болить.
Ще два роки тому Ольга навчалася в університеті на біолога,
підробляла в кол-центрі і навіть нянею.
Потім потрапила в лікарню і має ось такий результат - укорочену ногу.
Так сталося через те, що молода жінка припинила лікування.
Ользі щомісяця потрібна одна ампула тоцилізумабу
вартістю в півтори тисячі доларів.
А державні закупівлі біологічної терапії не проводяться з2018-го року.
Востаннєя приймала препарат у липні2018-го.
Через це в мене погіршився стан багатьох суглобів.
У Тетяни Барлас на ЮРА хвора донька.
Жінка очолює громадську організацію, яка піклується про таких пацієнтів.
В Україні з ціє хворобою борються
наразі 262 дорослих і ще майже 700 дітей.
ГО "Радість руху" за останні два роки зробила багато,
аби про потреби хворих на ЮРА дізналися в міністерстві охорони здоров'я.
Раніше фінансування терапії пацієнтів після 18-ти років
за бюджетний кошт не передбачалося.
У 2018 році громадські організації добилися,
аби закупівлю ліків для дорослих хворих
цієї орфанною хворобою включили в держбюджет.
Уперше в історії Україні в бюджеті2019-го року
передбачені 64 млн гривень на закупівлю ліків для ЮРА
для таких, як Оля, яка зараз втратила суглоб і не може ходити.
Вся необхідна робота вже зроблена.
З серпня документи чекають на підпис,
на те, щоб була реально здійснена закупівля.
Чому представники нового уряду не підписали документи,
Тетяна Барлас не знає.
Насправді в МОЗі були заблоковані документи не лише на закупівлю ліків для хворих на ЮРА.
Як стверджувала ще одна громадська організація "Пацієнти України"
в своєму відкритому зверненні, не підписані кошториси
бо заблоковане постачання препаратів для лікування важких та рідкісних хвороб
на суму в 1, 6 мільярда гривень.
Це здебільшого були гроші для закупівель через міжнародні організації.
У МОЗі стверджують, що дізналися про проблему з ліками фактично з соцмереж.
А коли почали робити аудит, то нібито з’ясували,
що реєстру таких хворих немає, що не усе в порядку
з документацією для проведення закупівель ліків,
яка дісталася від команди попередньої міністерки Уляни Супрун.
Зараз це питання, якевиникло, воновиникло
через нефаховість інепрофесіоналізм частини команди міністерства,
ще до того часу, коли прийшла міністр.
Несвоєчасне повідомлення, неподача документів у встановленому порядку.
Міністерка - юристка, вона подивилася і сказала: Ні, хлопці! Так не можна…
МОЗ запевняє, що чиновники, які не змогли
вчасно і правильно підготувати документацію,
будуть притягнуті до дисциплінарної відповідальності.
Водночас співробітники МОЗу, які прийшли впроваджувати реформи кілька років тому,
заявили, що на них чиниться тиск,
а питання закупівель і розподілу ліків заблоковано через те,
що нова команда не цілковито підтримує реформи, що впроваджувалися раніше.
Співробітники МОЗу і пацієнтські організації висловили ще більшу стурбованість тим,
що в держбюджеті наступного року команда президента Зеленського
заклала ще менше коштів на важкі хвороби, ніж зараз.
Зараз ми бачимо, що в принципі
фінансування всіх захворювань забезпечується нашою державою
близько 50% .
На2020 рік
порізали фінансування орфанних хворих.
Тобто фактично всього 20% хворих отримують доступ до ліків.
Наприклад, якщо говорити конкретними цифрами,
то пацієнти з торсійною дистонією,
їх було заплановано 15 прооперувати в цьому році,
зможуть прооперувати лише 5.
Радник міністра охорони здоров’я Раїмов запевняє,
що ніхто не згортає реформи, ситуація вже під контролем,
йде широкий діалог з пацієнтськими організаціями.
Мовляв, МОЗ скерував до Верховної Ради пропозиції
щодо внесення змін в держбюджет в частині фінансування важких хвороб,
йде пошук додаткових коштів в місцевих бюджетах.
Але "дива" в МОЗі чекати не радять.
Чи можна гарантувати, що усім буде все?Це буде брехня!
Але можна ефективнішевикористовуватиці гроші.
Наприклад, запустити трансплантацію в Україні
і можна ефективніше далі лікуватилюдей в Україні.
Тим часом Ольга Ткаченко намагається розтягнути одну знеболювальну пігулку
на довше, ніж один день.
На знеболювальних вона живе вже рік.
Молода жінка знає, що без терапії може втратити суглоб і на нозі,
а потім ще і тазостегновий.
І каже, що в цьому сенсі їй байдуже,
команда якої міністерки припустилася помилки
чи то працює не в інтересах хворих.
Ми не вимагаємо того, що вони не можуть зробити.
Я сподіваюся, що вони просто збагнуть, що нам теж хочеться жити.
Ольга має лише пенсію в півтори тисячі гривень.
Вона хоче працювати, аби не висіти на шиї у своєї родини,
хоче піти на курси і вчитися на диктора - озвучувати ролики, фільми, аудіокниги.
Утім, навіть якщо завтра з’являться її ампули,
в норму вона прийде лише через кілька місяців.
А вже наступного року, ймовірно, знову можуть початися перебої з препаратами.
Торік хворі вже ходили на мітинг під Мінфін уряду Володимира Гройсмана
вимагати виділення достатніх коштів на цей рік.
Якщо попри обіцянки МОЗу ситуація не зміниться,
Ольга готова разом з іншими йти знов на пікет.
Вже проти уряду Гончарука.
За умови, звісно, якщо постійний біль вдасться втамувати таблетками.